quando ela é ignorante
tudo é na raça decifração um mal ou não
porque nem sempre percebemos os sinais à
nossa volta
affonso romano de sant'anna pessoal eu
sou jung em a eu tinha que falar de um
assunto específico um problema que afeta
todos nós mas também à fala vai ao
encontro é da fao da e ajeitar lajida na
da unir e também de todos é uma fala que
também vai de certa forma vai ao
encontro dessa questão de fazer algo pra
mudar com alguma coisa que muda porque o
universo interior ea partir disso você
pode mudar o universo dos homens mas eu
vim aqui falar pra vocês especificamente
sobre o problema que afeta todos nós
há o problema da não leitura a na
leitura de literatura bom mas tanto faz
se tornasse americana muita falta é dito
seguinte ele insistiu que a literatura
fazer o que você vai ficar uns ossos no
campo e meia da noite
o fórum reunirá quase nada mas permite
ver quando a escuridão ao redor
a literatura ela é crucial aprendizados
do aprendizagem do ser humano
a literatura nos permite é é usar
muda a recortar interpretar a realidade
alguns autores nos dão instrumentos
lentes é que nos ajudam ver os aspectos
do real e do simbólico
alguns autores inventar motos de ver tv
com dois exemplos aqui o amigo vai na
festa recorda escutava a festa tá ruim
ficar distante rapidamente você percebe
que a festa estava insuportável que tem
nos deu esse modo de venda importante
ele é obra e fé
mais um exemplo após a leitura da obra o
processo do escritor tcheco franz kafka
é no que entra numa repartição pública
vai ver ela da mesma maneira
o cenário foi montado por ele a
literatura e todos permite que novas
leituras de mundo de novas leituras de
nós mesmo
o ministério da educação e oferece a
alguns programas de incentivo à leitura
acho que infelizmente nos carros não
atingiriam não é o caso do mundo é e 8
são ineficazes
no brasil infelizmente nós não atingimos
níveis satisfatórios para afirmar os que
temos um público comprometido com com a
lei fica aqui é o que aponta a última
pesquisa do instituto pró livro
em outra pesquisa realizada recentemente
pela revista americana the economist
a volta de neymar só 11 não nunca de 30
países nós estamos em último
o time do assinante ocupamos 27º lugar
estamos à frente apenas de países como
paraguai
aí a polícia é e angola
ah ah ah ah na europa por exemplo na
europa eles lei de dez avanços seguidos
por ano
aqui no brasil nós lemos de dois a
quatro livros
essa é a nossa realidade aqui os livros
vocês nem por ano
quando se leva até agora estamos em
março
bom eu a mostrar aqui alguns fatores vou
comentar que seja um dos fatores que
contribui com esse número negativo é é a
falta de leitura
muitas famílias não têm orçamentos livro
algumas famílias vivem em situação de
precariedade na nossa escola e ainda é
vencer uma copa é a fé é que não quer
trocar de pele
isso foi comentado a equipe os mesmos
moldes ela não muda é aluno entra em
forma ele senta é é a i em fila ele não
pode compartilhar o mesmo que circular
só coisa do século 19
aí fora um bom de conhecimento à
internet a novos pensamentos mas a
escola não ganha há a falta de leitura
de alguns professores algumas condições
que existem não trabalhar com com textos
literários e saúde ao trabalho com
apenas ter textos informativos da agile
alagoas tem uma tendência de produzir
de resto a aaa literário roundhill só
ver a gramática erro
despediu se retrai as cerejas ocupam as
cerejas do bolo são dimas
a primeira a sociedade do espetáculo
como decidir de morte
as mídias ó eu deixo famílias que é
ficam na frente da tv assistindo o
programa de auditório
achei que fosse um problema quando é de
algo de valor mas destaca se a gente
colocar um campo lá dentro do programa
de virar outra coisa a outra cirurgia
para colocar tinta azul
muitas pessoas ficam replicamos coisas
lá no facebook se com thalma social do
conedes no facebook muitas vezes ele é
apenas um tranqüilizante pro a falta de
conhecimento pra solidão nossa é as
pessoas como elas compartilham um texto
de uma escritora já ouviu falar com
alice está entre as pessoas usavam
consigo aprendendo como eu concordar mas
o pastor nada me faltará na casa você
queria ter vários links mas a gente não
leva a lugar nenhum
bom vocês não havendo falar artistas
devem pensar na sul gelson ctl livros em
casa e contações de histórias do pai pai
e minha mãe contava histórias uma bela
estante de livros não é entre aqui os
portões é a vocês estão o pessoal aqui é
no palco está um pouco
é bom essa não é a realidade
então não vem de família entrada eu
mantenho a não teve contato algum com a
literatura na infância eu sou para mas
eu cresci em um ambiente urbano
a ponta grossa há na minha família não
tinha orçamento para o river na escola
uma escola afastada do interior não
tinha uma biblioteca muitas vezes a vida
é um farol prometido mas ele tinha
apenas um armário com livros didáticos é
então eu cresci no ambiente sem livros
está em contração da história da
literatura infantil
a contação de história ela é escola de
vida ela a escola de complexidade humana
para a criança ao geraldes cobra muita
sensibilidade multiplicidade de cada ser
é fundamental pra criança reformular não
apenas a criança o adulto que também
reformula sonhar a criança precisa
sonhar mas infelizmente não era possível
o único sonho possível o único sonho é
que deixado aquele é o meu avô antes de
falecer
rodolfo medina já o meia entrada mas
após o desaparecimento dele faleceu
muito certo eu não tiver conhecemos
fazendo com 40 anos é é a minha avó
a companheira dele era analfabeta e ele
prevendo então que algo poderia
acontecer e com o desaparecimento dele
eles foram a nigéria porque minha avó
foi de goleada mas ele deixou um recado
pra minha mãe feliz e minha filha quando
o meu neto nascer você diga para se
aproximar dos livros the gun é pro meu
neto
diga sim e pina laina dó nem alega estar
sozinho
é isso e rota considerada absurda era
num bairro de famílias abastadas marcon
casas luxuosas casas de caminho eram
castelos 40 imagens do castelo
eu ficava sonhando e até que os castelos
mas seria o castelo que eu ia morar e
diante de um desses castelos enquanto
telmo jogado no lixo tudo daria minha
vida para sempre
encontrei uma maletinha eu apertava os
botões aí a cantar um alto falante
dentro do previsto deveriam e junto
cinco discos o primeiro disco quando eu
olhei a mãe ficou assustado na capa
tinha 11 demônio e uma cadeira eu estava
escrita em uma língua que não entendia
de instituir uma idéia foi levar a
estatueta para casa
aí o segundo era uma fábrica parte do
corpo humano do self foi atrás de quem
influente o terceiro o total de
eleitores em mim aí o natal de lax amat
e matou de casa de 2010 na casa correia
na porta de madeira ltda ambiental
quando eu abrir a qual é sabido bom acho
que esse foi o dia começava o povo
começar a água começava pelo cabelo
coloca o disco na agulha
mesmo com o sol vai ditar o meu coração
eu fiquei emocionado
a apaixonada que ia ser aqueles caras da
banda é aquelas as ditadas
a lista tinha mas de repente eu atinente
ao som se emociona é que você quer ser
que 20 na mãe
eu preciso escrever uma cadelinha ti
lunai levo a minha profissão antiga uma
pessoa o meu filho antes de uma língua
mas avançou na ilha atravessa a
sensibilidade ela sabia da minha
realidade não me mate do sonho com esse
professor que lecionava limpeza então
esse professor gelson a nota as letras
do caderno que eu estava no bar das
traduções e com o apoio desse professor
na helmand por 3 x 0
eu encontrei amões eu encontrei e ligará
lançou o pai como policial nestas
histórias de terror o mistério fica
montado um universo fantástico nunca dei
bola preta aquelas histórias a na
notícia ou com o corpo humano do seu a
primeira música pizza segunda data xix
da prostituição falando de johnson aqui
a pink floyd estão falando de uma obra
importantíssima o escritor inglês
chamado george o nome da obra após a
revolução dos bichos e aí então fui
eleito a paraíba eu ficava escreveria a
partir da leitura do short oro eu
entendi que ser humano senão não conhece
os seus direitos não se forma instrução
foi facilmente dominado manipulados ea
em cada disco na nossa literatura se a
casa tiver que me baby transmutou com o
universo futurista eu fui avançando
agora no quarto eu tinha um sonho que eu
tinha algo fora dele a realidade de
chapada no ano inclua extrema
precariedade precariedade uma linha
invisível uma fronteira invisível que
atua
há diferenças importantes nas duas
experiências sociais a inclusão a
inclusão tem que vir e precariedade de
sua oferta
milhares de pessoas neste país uma
sociedade de consumo
aquele que tem um pé dentro e fora
aquele que consome a marca é exaltado
aqueles que não têm acesso a marca
apagados escolhidos
bom a eu fui a avançando com as
literaturas muitas foi a extrema
dificuldade em fazer já foi o sorveteiro
frentista é tocador de obras e de por
sanduíche natural que eu mesmo fazia e
foi avançando a trabalhar no comércio
até cheguei foi para uma livraria já um
homem feito nessa situação muito difícil
você foi parar em uma livraria e nessa
livraria e rapidamente o destaque por
conta das minhas leituras e rapidamente
é um em naawa é um coordenando o setor
de livros
bom agora o caso consoante a viajar
difícil bauhaus de filme de james joyce
bolsa bala duas coreias mas é um homem
feito e me permiti encantar pela
literatura infantil e mergulhei no setor
de livros infantis
amei aquela obra se emocionavam
invocavam ficava esperando de teoria das
escolas falavam com as gestoras com as
professoras e alan e permitiu que eu
falasse com os alunos ativo que cantava
eu passava com amor
então é no refeitório na sala de aula
debaixo de uma árvore e aquelas crianças
começa a chegar mesmo a oitava no futuro
falar de livros e teses do livro
o meio-campo meca vamos conversar pronto
uma verdadeira revolução eu a a hatay o
quanto o gato preto ou ligar uma boa no
que contava de atingir os meninos e um
bicudo que não não sabem que nunca tinha
entrado a pé
agora aquele livro do gato preto eu
quero que os pequenos que não contar
histórias estão agora fazendo o caminho
contrário os as crianças estavam
contando histórias faz e e eu sempre
falo assim até hoje paulo oferece
histórias aos seus pais e sabe que eles
estão tão estranhos não lembra a
importância de contar uma história por
um filho uma filha mas tem um horário
especial para contar a história do país
sabe qual é
nem na hora da novela bom eu fui lá a
avançando nesse trabalho com certeza é
uma instituição que trabalha em um ponto
num espaço com livros em uma biblioteca
maravilhosa é os contemporâneos os
clássicos nas obras que estavam há 23
anos novinha segundo empréstimo estava
nas horas na praia
aí fiz uma uma parceria lá com minha
história eu chego às oito da manhã e
evitar algumas crianças e gente em seis
meses de atendimento nessa mesma pega eu
tenho pequenos empréstimos da biblioteca
e aí então eu percebi e aí eu senti a
mensagem do meu corpo na lagoa e na rua
principal é que eu precisava sair eu
tinha uma missão e ainda é o batizei com
o nome das cidades como tia de leitura
fundadora e pedir demissão se instalou
todo mundo me chama de louco mas eu
precisava circular eu precisava oferecer
porque tinha mudado seu universo
interior eu precisava pagar conta como
um chá ea eu comecei em 2010 atendeu
algumas cidades é rádio jaraguá do sul
a inove 11 circulem por 22 cidades
através de parcerias tv o agrada
pra fazer que fazer mediação com arnaldo
antunes
a taf loucos largo márcia de buy comprar
mais em 2003 é um desafio mas me
interessa se der um desafio de é
relevado literatura no presídio
o diretor falou 'você tá maluco rapaz
médio ler poemas vai falar de
encantamento
mas eu vou deixar só para atacar não
sair eu aceitei mas eu estou literatura
filho já te dá é f chocou história da
loucura games beleza e quando sair com
ela os caras estavam estocados em um
lugar assim alguma coisa e através desse
projeto que é o projeto do outro agora
eles têm um companheiro em uma
biblioteca só pra eles e o gol eles têm
um projeto se chama página de liberdade
àqueles que não iam agora estão lendo
aqueles que já vinham agora estão
contando a sua história é não publicar
um livro contando a história dele e
quando eles saírem eles têm alguma mas
vamos tentar o mesmo ponto mas voltaram
diferentes
bom o projeto de lei que hoje circula
por tocantins alagoas rio grande do
norte é mato grosso paraná é não não não
farei mais resultados que fosse com a
sua teoria em 2003 participou comigo
o projeto hoje ela me série dizendo que
ela é contadora de história aqui em
lages uma outra favorita para se comer
newey 13 hoje ela está fazendo
biblioteconomia ninguém no chile em 2012
agora fernando ensino médio escreveu que
está terminado escrevendo um tcc sobre
rock e literatura é professores de não
conseguir dialogar os alunos às urnas de
velhice se constroem sala de aula agora
se consegue os alunos conseguem entender
que leitura é tecnologia de
transferência de tecnologia
bom será que nesse pelo norte deixa a
gente vai ficar aqui mas eu vou encerrar
a agora trará a a imagem do castelo vão
encerrar
é uma história que eu adaptei é uma
história de princesa
o nome da história é valentina do márcio
vassalo essa história da princesa
valentina de como o da princesa filha de
rei e rainha como toda a princesa marie
castelo
o rei é branco a rainha é negra
a valentina ea beleza da menina pessoal
no rap página de vidro
às vezes lá no alto do castelo aparecida
valentina fica um pouco assustada porque
do lado de fora do sistema do futebol e
gostei fogo e fazer muito barulho
neste momento o rei ea rainha abraça uma
valentina com pensamentos carinhosos e
contam histórias pra ela
assim ela se distrai e não recebe do
lado de fora
estranho que a prudência a promessa e
som cunha que é uma princesa
lá no alto do castelo precisamente na
conserva a cidade lá embaixo do nome da
cidade é tudo um dia à noite na 10 e 11
anos para ver como tudo é que quando ela
chegava em seu lugar chamado de anã têm
uma surpresa lá no futuro todas as
meninas estivessem muito iguais roupa
nas roupas parecidas as mesmas marcas
dos celulares da moda os mesmos
trejeitos as dez dias de passe e todas
têm um som em comum todos os sonhos em
princesas
a noite não chega se apresenta como
princesa todas as meninas de roupa de
marcas circulares da moda
a equipe de bocha e se é assim você
precisa um declínio adicional de vendas
princesa então nós temos que o castelo
da princesa valentina aqui toda precisa
não de castelo e valentina se ofende
rosa aponta lá pessoal lá está o castelo
vejam quanto dos outros castelos e as
meninas quando olham como bosch
é uma mentira na verdade humana por
barracos em uma favela no morro no rio
de janeiro e às vezes do lado de fora do
barracão quando os dragões que cospem
fogo
os pais a noite na praça maior convenção
- carinhosos encontra opções assim ela
percebe que acontece do lado de fora do
bairro
nesse momento com vários vira castelo o
pai irá ele ea mãe de valentina tomar
satisfação
os livros não mudam o mundo
os mesmos montam as pessoas as pessoas
mudam o mundo mais um ano
obrigado